olá é um prazer estar aqui
nunca pensei poderá apresentar alguma
coisa no técnico
tive 9.45 matemática que é 9.5 que lech
conseguir para minha cidade é privada
mas estou a tirar a comunicação social
não se adaptou e como no meio de semana
tem 21 anos e é um prazer imenso estar
aqui é e acima de tudo vem cá falar com
quem tenho aqui notas que eu estou
habituado a apresentações 4m primeira
apresentação sem evoluções minha
situação atual é assim eu ganhei o
kassin dano da câmera da marinha 9 fm
estou a estudar comunicação social como
jafri e também faz vídeos para o youtube
de vez em quando
acima de tudo de que o youtube quer como
se tivéssemos alcoólicos anônimos têm um
problema qualquer
portanto é um ganho cassinho da campanha
de marina ao fim e acima de tudo a
ganhar e sobretudo devido ao alto é
porque através do youtube conseguir uma
uma base de seguidores que influenciou
bastante a escolha do das pessoas tenham
que escolher arrastava e também é a
joana cruz o andré henriques também
tiveram parte nessa nessa escolha é
normalmente não faço estas apresentações
porque eu acho que nunca tem nada para
dizer
é essa aí hoje não sei porque talvez por
ser o técnico mas tocar e quando saiu a
cena do youtube em 2012
é quando quando o youtube vender algo
mais ou menos mais 30 do que é agora
hoje em dia tentar ser um youtube é
difícil porque há muita concorrência há
muita qualidade e tentar ser o youtube
hoje em dia é difícil eu comecei em 2012
conseguir angariar alguns credores
desde então tem o 30 e os vídeos no
canal 11 milhões de visualizações ao
todo
estou a tentar passar essa coisa
exatamente aqui estou eu no meio do
pessoal efe mrm/an tanto quando comecei
a fazer vídeos
isso eu com mais 10 quilos em cima é
quando eu comecei a fazer vídeos no
intuito original era fazer as pessoas
rir e talvez partilhar uma mensagem com
essas mesmas pessoas
o normal é o então também era bastante
social
uma dessas e como o frita e os meias
visualizações autor neste canal
para além de já ter feito vídeos em
outros canais do youtube é canais
secundários e o meu percurso académico
nunca como já falei não foi não foi o
ideal é o gestor nem refeno não pelo
percurso académico mas mais pelo youtube
que é uma coisa estranha futebol não
conseguir fazer por três razões de cada
do joelho aos 15 anos jogava mal e
gostava muito do nosso cuidado comentou
nós avisou pronto é que está esse foi um
novo vídeo mais popular foi sobre o
sporting eo benfica foi isso que
explodiu como o canal é e que fecha
iniciar várias atividades profissionais
foi um vídeo que obteve 3 milhões e mais
visualizações e falava sobre a província
é uma época o sporting nenhum adepto do
benfica é a discutirem sobre o do
sporting estava gostando tristonho
benfica estava ali a dizer que era o
melhor
mais ou menos à situação atual
infelizmente 5 1 o braga é rico não sei
como é
enfim ele foi a partir desse momento que
consegue ganhar alguma notoriedade
não estou dizendo que sou maior análises
mas comecei a ganhar alguns credores
com isso é fui obtendo vários empregos é
hoje em dia em estudo mas já fiz parte
do imol já fez polícia pra aproximou se
hoje em dia embaixador dan dan da luta
efe que é uma concorrente da roche e da
yorn embaixador da marca já participou
em alguns programas de televisão já fui
entrevistá lo algumas vezes é e tudo
isso graças ao youtube
portanto é que mais vale do youtube é
mesmo a nossa base de hoje conseguimos
obter através dos conteúdos que nós
fomos nós quem e como já disse foi isso
que o diferenciou nos diferencia dos
outros concorrentes é nuno cassinho da
rádio já falhou no caso da rádio e eu
nunca pensei em ganhar é é colocar sim
porque escreveram as duas mil pessoas
pensei talvez chegar longe e também não
tenho hábito em escrever em casino já
havia um pé pra escrever nunca assim da
torno não sou isso tenham bastante
tímido como comentário é
mas ganhei sobretudo devido ao alto quer
mostrar sobretudo o poder que o culto
tem e algumas pela calma e algumas
pessoas perguntam se a cultura é assim
tão tão poderoso
o pib pode ser que sim é possível virar
culto cunha do youtube do que o de pai é
o youtube mas subscrito atualmente
internacionalmente também ganha dezenas
de milhões de de euros por ano e o ga em
30 por mês é quase igual e pronto acima
de tudo viver do youtube em portugal né
não dá
algumas pessoas conseguem mas vivem
somente daqui o todos disponham vídeo
são os gamers usam os jogos e fazem
vídeos através disso e pronto acima de
tudo o youtube é hoje em dia uma
plataforma extremamente poderosa a cada
minuto estão a ser postos em vídeos
constantemente 300 horas de vídeo por
minutos ou seja demoraríamos 50 anos
para poder ver o conteúdo todo que
alguém é que os criadores puseram neste
dia 50 anos é o youtube também uma
democratização do conteúdo seja o gene
toda a gente pode fazer o upload de
conteúdo de ser um seu jornalista é e
promover assim também mudanças sociais
sem entendermos dos media tradicionais
também trouxe os de outubro
o setúbal tem uma conexão com o público
de frente das celebridades tradicionais
acima de tudo é uma relação mais pessoal
uma relação mais autêntica e uma relação
mais independente não estamos presos a
marcas e parece que estamos a falar
diretamente com quem está a ver
hum no entanto anda com o youtube
evoluiu e se cada vez mais difícil
porque existe uma saturação do contínuo
existe bastante público mas antigamente
era bem mais fácil quando eu entrei em
hoje em dia é o youtube profissional
risos
existem estúdios que que existem para
fazer só conteúdo do projeto e fazem
milhões de euros por mês
eu queria também falar do futuro do
youtube não sabem o facebook já é tem
possibilidade de já tem possibilidade de
colocar vídeos no facebook o que vai
alterar um pouco o panorama dos vídeos é
que estão aqui é como podem ver gráfico
que é extremamente complexo
mostra que o facebook está à frente do
egito em termos de visualizações
isto porque é bem mais fácil ver um
vídeo no facebook do que está aí a
ligação eo próprio algoritmo do facebook
faz com que os vídeos que nós vemos
sejam mais virais no facebook
no entanto como podemos dizer que o
défice de atenção das pessoas no
facebook é totalmente diferente no
youtube a atenção do facebook após 30
segundos dó de ver um vídeo é apenas um
quinto das pessoas para é isso que eu
quero dizer é após 30 anos apenas 1 500
pessoas
está a ver o vídeo no facebook e no
youtube
cerca de 4 500 portanto sim o facebook
tem mais visualizações na sess
postumamente por estarmos a fazer scroll
mesmo assim estão a fazer scroll e que
conta com uma visualização passar a ter
três pontos portanto basicamente som são
visualizações um pouco falsas
e pronto hum acima de tudo gostaria de
dizer que essa desculpa é dar um exemplo
está em 4 que está eles é combater o
spam quest parte de um vídeo no facebook
quantas visualizações obteve 880 mil
tenho um número incrível do haiti o
número incrível de partilhas é e está
mais ou menos a contradizer por isso é
que as pessoas gostaram mesmo do vídeo
ou seja o facebook estes dois aspectos
têm aqui tem que eu espero que as
pessoas venham vídeo e crescem
rapidamente mas este vídeo é talvez é um
contratante qualquer isso porque no
youtube
este mesmo vídeo tem 60 mil
visualizações
no fundo o facebook vai alterar um pouco
o panorama dos filhos agora pode ser
denominado do facebook youtube já não
chega mas pronto concluindo esta
apresentação é estranho
o que quero dizer é que o youtube graças
ao youtube
eu consegui ganhar o carinho da menina
alvim consegui é ter alguns empregos que
não teria se não tivesse no youtube e
acima tudo publicidade
hoje em dia tem que estar atenta aos
influenciadores que estão no youtube é e
é isso que eu quero dizer com licença e
na escola é bem mais fácil
exatos o futuro da publicidade no
youtube bem como facebook youtube e
facebook são uma ferramenta de
propaganda como já frio youtube é a
razão pela qual estou aqui é dar uma
apresentação um pouco mas também a razão
pela qual eu tive essas oportunidades
todas talvez um dia vou poder fazer
alguma coisa como o curso para já tem
sido o youtube como trouxe até aqui